[Music]
uh that cat is scruffy
yeah it's a long uh you know something i
invited him and he's actually a big fan
of your work scott but um i guess
he gets intimidated by directors
well i'm happy that certainly somebody
at collider likes it steve
being serious uh scott the last time we
spoke about antlers it was you guillermo
and i and and we were talking about
disneyland and you mentioned you had
never been and guillermo offered to take
you
have you been able to go with guillermo
yet you know i haven't and he has
invited me to go again but i've been on
location uh
prepping a film i'm about to shoot but i
would love for just guillermo and me to
go to learn how much fun that would be
oh my god i just want to point out all
the people right now who are watching
this who are basically realizing you
have an invitation to go with guillermo
to disneyland like the two of you and
you're like yeah i'm too busy i can't do
that
well it's not so much that i'm too busy
but but i am it's but i'm out of the
state otherwise i would make it a point
and prepping a movie that i'm about to
start shooting in about a month so um
but i vow to go
with guillermo del toro i'm so curious
what guillermo's um sell on disneyland
is what are his favorite spots like one
question but he loves it and he loves to
go and he likes to take people yeah yeah
yeah i will i've valkyrie i'm feeling
guillermo likes everything like he's so
alive and interested and curious about
everything do you know what i mean
that's just how he is
he's like oh my gosh let's go let's
taste everything let's do everything
yeah um also he loves haunted mansion so
i would imagine that would be your first
possibly first question without a
question sure copy yes so uh
curious if neither if someone has never
seen
anything you guys have done before what
is the thing you want them to start with
oh god oh boy uh what did you say well
that's a very good question
because after my first film crazy art
which was a much warmer film i love
crazy my films then became progressively
darker what happened uh because steve
the world became progressively darker
right and i could go through all those
reasons why and i'm just holding a
mirror up to life and and what it
reflects back to me is what i've found
in my films because i've always loved
the work of ken loach with the dan
brothers and nobody really uh
highlights the the the ills that uh
inflict upon a society as well as those
guys
what's it gonna take to get you back to
crazy but i have to get back to what is
it gonna take yes i think i'm starting
uh starting to trend back that way
because i'm feeling so much more hopeful
about life
but perhaps it would be crazy hard
because jeff bridges by saying yes to
that i wrote it specifically for him
uh he changed my life by saying yes
and if not for jeff i can assure you i
would not be sitting here next to the
glamorous and talented kerry russell so
great in that and what about you carrie
what what what from your work oh brother
i don't know um
waitress felicity oh god two great great
performances guys would it be the
americans which is classic tv well you
know i think i think i've got to go with
obvious choice the bon jovi video the
bon jovi video did you know that she was
in the bon jovi video i did not know you
were in the bon jovi video yeah i did
you gotta look that up bring a green bra
it's my finest work
yeah i will be linking to it for sure in
this interview yeah i'm amazing
i'm pretty great
um carrie i am curious what was it about
the script and story for antlers that
says
that said i i want to do this
i wanted to work with scott honestly
like i i i am genuinely a fan of his
aesthetic of his movies and
and i thought
it was unique that he was going to try
to do this horror movie and i think uh
what he and and florian our
cinematographer they created this really
kind of elegant
gritty
moody horror movie and um
it was everything i wanted it to be
so it was really just the filmmakers
that were involved
um one of the things that i really enjoy
one of the many things i really enjoy
about this movie is that you're dealing
with what's going on in the real world
without like without the film like being
preachy you know and can you sort of
both talk about that aspect of antlers
yeah that was the biggest challenge that
i faced steve because
you know for being honest my
sensibilities and guillermos are almost
diametrically opposed right in terms of
my very grounded experience and his kind
of fantastical whimsical and
and he always finds
humor in his work uh
some of mine uh lacks um so look it's a
miracle that that any of this uh uh
works uh successfully and also
um uh again in trying to hold up a
mirror to all of the fears and anxieties
that americans are facing there a lot
and uh in my research with
grace dylan who's the indigenous
professor at portland state university
she
and i was i was writing the script and
sharing it with her and she said scott
but that's what the windigo represents
it takes many many forms and and it's
first and foremost to spirit but it
deals with the desecration of our
natural resources and shared grief and
abuse and addiction all the sort of
things that course through the film and
she was guiding me as an expert as to uh
as to what uh ails us now and what the
windigo represents
uh so that was it for me but i i really
appreciate that you liked it thank you
okay what was the question again i don't
know i said something about the movie
i'm joking i also love cats
right she loves cats she dances with bon
jovi
no it was the fact that the movie deals
with a lot of what's going on in the
world but it's not preachy about it
right yeah and i think um
i also
like kind of the math i had to do in my
head or i do in my head as an actor
you know about the monster and
everything to me it was just sort of a
metaphor the monster is the
the scary stuff for me
the scary stuff is always you know
kids like kids being left kind of
unattended and
terrible things happening to kids that's
like an easy
a an easy go-to for a parent to
you know find
so i i think um
yeah i think
horror movies have always done that
right like poltergeist is
really about
a family falling apart sort of or
i think that's and you can elevate
things with horror movies if the stakes
can be higher really easily um
but yeah i think scott's version was a
grounded version for me to enter into
this genre
on that note i gotta stop i'm just gonna
say scott i'm very happy you're about to
start filming another movie sincerely
and i really thank you steve no i i i'm
i'm assuming it's the one with bail
it is the one with uh with christian
bale yeah it's our third together and uh
i hope to speak to you again soon and i
always enjoy our chats
you